by now we have defined the notion of
independence of events and also the
notion of independence of random
variables the two definitions look
fairly similar but the details are not
exactly the same because the two
definitions refer to different
situations for two events we know what
it means for them to be independence the
probability of their intersection is the
product of their individual
probabilities now to make a relation
with random variables we introduced the
so called indicator random variables so
for example the random variable X is
defined to be equal to 1 if event a
occurs and to be equal to 0 if event
does not occur and there is a similar
definition for random variable Y in
particular the probability that random
variable X takes the value of 1 this is
the probability that event a occurs it
turns out that the independence of the
two events a and B is equivalent to the
independence of the two indicator random
variables and there is a similar
statement which is true more generally
that is and events are independent if
and only if be associated an indicator
random variables are independent this is
a useful statement because it allows us
to sometimes instead of manipulating
events to manipulate random variables
and vice versa and depending on the
context one may be easier than the other
now the intuitive content is that event
a and B are independent if the
occurrence of event a does not change
your beliefs about B and in terms of
random variables one random variable
taking a certain value which indicates
whether event a has occurred or not does
not give you any information about the
other random variable which would tell
you whether event B has occurred or not
it is instructive now to go through the
derivation of this
at least for the case of two events
because it gives us perhaps some
additional understanding about the
precise content of the definitions we
have introduced so let us suppose that
random variables x and y are independent
what does that mean independence means
that the joint pmf of the two random
variables x and y factors as a product
of the corresponding marginal pmfs and
this factorization must be true no
matter what arguments we use inside the
joint pmf and the combination of x and y
in this instance have a total of four
possible values these are the
combinations of zeros and ones that we
can form and for this reason we have a
total of four equations these four
equality's are what is required for x
and y to be independent so suppose that
this is true the trend that the random
variables are independent let us take
this first relation and write it in
probability notation the random variable
X taking the value of 1 that's the same
as event a occurring and random variable
Y taking the value of 1 that's the same
as event B occurring so the joint PMF
evaluated at 1 1 is the probability that
events a and B both occur on the other
side of the equation we have the
probability that X is equal to 1 which
is a probability that a occurs and
similarly the probability that B occurs
but if this is true then by definition a
and B are independent events so we have
verified one direction of the statement
if the random variables are independent
then events a and B are independent now
we would like to verify the reverse
statement so suppose that events a and B
are independent in that case this
relation is true and as we just argued
this relation is the
as this relation but just written in
different notation so we have song that
if a and B are independent this relation
will be true but how about the remaining
three relations we have more work to do
here's how we can proceed if a and B are
independent we have shown some time ago
that events a and B complement will also
be independent intuitively a doesn't
tell you anything about B occurring or
not
so a does not tell you anything about
whether B complement will occur or not
now these two events being independent
by the definition of Independence we
have that the probability of a
intersection with B complement is the
product of the probabilities of a and of
B complement and then we realize that
this equality is written in PMF notation
corresponds exactly to this equation
here a event a corresponds to X taking
the value of one event B complement
corresponds to the event that Y takes
the value of zero by similar arguments B
and a complement will be independent and
we translate that into probability
notation
and then we translate this equality into
PMF notation and we get this relation
finally using the same property that we
use to do the first step here we have
that a compliment and B complement are
also independent and by following the
same line of reasoning this applies the
fourth relation as well so we have
verified that if events a and B are
independent then we can argue that all
of these four equations will be true and
therefore random variables x and y will
also be independent